foreign
if I had to pick a topic that I feel
like is more important than I realized
when I was writing the book I would
probably say this and that's the power
of the social environment
you know we are all part of multiple
tribes sometimes those tribes are like
large like what it means to be American
and sometimes they're they're small like
what it means to be a neighbor on your
street or a member of the local gym but
all of those tribes that you belong to
the large groups and the small groups
they all have this set of expectations
they've got a set of social norms for
what you do when you're in that group
and what the typical way is to act and
behave and what kind of habits they
follow and
the more that your habits go with the
grain of the expectations of the group
The more attractive they feel like to
you because it's like hey I fit in I
belong I'm part of something
and the more that they go against the
grain of the expectations of the group
the harder they are to stick to
especially in the long run maybe you can
do it for a day or a week or I don't
know a month or two but like at some
point you kind of keep rubbing against
you have this like friction where you're
conflicting with the group and it
becomes hard to stick to that for the
long run and so the little takeaway that
I kind of think of now is
you want to join groups to join tribes
where your desired behavior is the
normal behavior because if it's normal
in that group then it becomes really
motivating to stick to it you know and
furthermore the the kind of like
ancillary habits that are part of that
group that the other expectations are
things that you're probably going to
soak up like
people will join a CrossFit gym because
they think they want to get in shape but
then you turn around six months later
and they're all eating paleo and wearing
the same brand of knee sleeves and they
buy the same workout gear and like it's
all these other habits that they never
intended to build but they just kind of
soaked them up because that's what the
group was doing and ultimately I think
this comes back to this kind of deep
need that we all have which is this need
to bond and connect you know we all want
to be a part of something we want to
belong we want to fit in
and if people have to choose between you
know I have habits that I don't really
love but I fit in I belong I'm part of
something or I have the habits that I
want to have but I'm cast out I'm
ostracized I'm criticized I mean most of
the time the desire to belong will
overpower the desire to improve so as
best as possible you got to get those
two things aligned and surround yourself
with people where your desired behavior
is the normal behavior
yeah absolutely
the whole you're the average of the five
people you associate with most type of
thinking and also for people who are
starting off the new year or about to
and thinking about
how to
best ensure that you cohere with a group
that
leads to these new behaviors front
loaded make it painful not to do it pay
in advance
right make make some type of bet with
one of your friends and you owe each
other money if you miss workouts like
set it up so it is painful not to do it
I know it's might sound like I'm
favoring The Stick Over The Carrot
you're also going to use the carrots
right sure you can use the carrots but
make it compelling from an incentives
perspective to do it as you said you can
also use the you know the carrots like
the the flip side of that is
so yes like make it painful not to do it
and make it easy and frictionless and
obvious to do it you know like try to
design your environment so the things
that you say are important to you are
the obvious and available things I think
one interesting thing you can do is walk
into the just think about one habit
you're trying to build and then walk
into the rooms where you spend most of
your time each day kitchen office
bedroom whatever and just look around
and ask yourself what behaviors are
obvious here you know what is this space
designed to encourage yeah and you'll
start to notice different things that
you can tweak to make it the good habit
more obvious and easier and the bad
habits or the things you want to avoid
less obvious and maybe a little higher
friction and making one or two little
adjustments like that is not going to
radically transform your life but if you
make a dozen or two dozen or fifty and
you're kind of all these environments
all these rooms where you're spending
space each day are primed to support the
habits you want to build
I mean you know now you've got a
Tailwind rather than a headwind and so
it's become so much easier to appear as
if you have great willpower or that
you're really consistent when really
you're benefiting from the environment
that you already set up